et
[Musique]
maintenant voici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Mitel
Eddie Michel bonsoir bonsoir merci vous
êtes habillé comme moi ça me touche
beaucoup c'est vous qui êtes habillé
comme ah pardon
excusez-moi ça va bien connaissez Sophie
Marceau oui l'actrice préférée des
Français ils ont bien raison et qui se
préoccupe donc de reporteur sans
frontière il faut que vous fassiez des
des photos vous savez puis après on les
vend aux enchères oui enfin je suis pas
douéez baffi vous pensez qu'il fait
faire des photos baffi oui alors vous
êtes aussi rare en télévision je dirais
que que Sophie Marceau merci d'avoir
choisi tout le monde en parle
pour parler de votre nouveau disque
alors on parlait de décoration avec
Sophie tout à l'heure elle a reçu une
médaille du ministre Jean-Jacques
aayagon vous baladure vous a proposé le
mérite mais vous l'avez refusé hein euh
oui puis la Légion d'Honneur tout la
Légion d'Honneur aussi ah ouais et vous
avez refusé aussi oui non il a un côté
militaire moi qui me dérou ouais ouis
vous préférez les discque d'or vous avez
dit ah oui je préfère ça honnêtement
Didier parle trop j'entends de char au
matin les M les
[Musique]
mêmes
oh
Dani
la on
esté a toujours
uns
si tu n'étais pas mon frère je n'aurais
pas eu de
pitié si tu n'étais pas mon frère je
crois que je paris tu es hier encore
j'avais de
amis s'il y en quelquun je se là V
oublier l'oublier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui la
route la lumièreevient
déjà et le film est terminé
je réveille mon
voisin
et la
[Musique]
voixcié il n'a plus qu'espoir plus
qu'espoir il ne rentre pas ce soir
en faisait un peu trop la f au Monal
hlywood est dans sa tête tout seule
[Applaudissements]
le des
éléphants où sont mes racineseville
Belleville où s mes racines V
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bille
[Musique]
j'ai un nouveau
télévision dans le blousier
terro bagabond chante
et es hors du
[Musique]
temps alors la dernière c'est route 66
donc extrait de votre nouvel album qui
s'appelle frenchy en plus j'en connais
[Musique]
aucune déjà
connu route 6